if we show you a random shape your eyes
will send the information to your brain
which will then decide what to do with
it perhaps not much
if we show you another shape your senses
will again send it to your brain but now
it might be able to find some related
information that was stored in your
memory what's going on here
you may have forgotten but when you were
young you knew nothing the first time
you saw a particular shape it was
meaningless over time and in search for
order you started to recognize patterns
one day someone gave that particular
thing meaning your mind labeled it as
important and decided to store it for
future use
the next time you see that thing you
recognize it and link it to a previous
experience the more often you make such
meaningful experiences the more data
will be stored in your memory and your
understanding of that matter grows
and one day when you see that particular
shape you'll say it's an ape and if you
give your mind some time to look up all
those memories it might come up with
lots of things you can relate to this
one piece of digital ink so how does
your memory work
[Music]
the multi-store model asserts that the
human brain has three processes a
sensory register where new information
enters a short-term memory which quickly
assesses the input and a long-term store
where it can potentially be held forever
we need attention to get things to the
short-term memory rehearsal to hold it
there for longer and transfer for
sending it to long-term storage and
bringing it back let's now try to
understand how everything interacts
our life is a continuous stream of
stimuli that we perceive in different
ways
there are senses such as Vision touch
smell hearing and taste there are
internal states such as stress
sleepiness or hunger and there are
emotions wants and intentions all of
them are part of the sensory input that
our brain has to process all the time
the sensory register can perceive any
such new stimuli they are then filtered
by attention processes and decomposed
into manageable chunks these chunks of
information are then sent further
the short-term memory holds the new info
for a moment then it will either forget
it transfer it to the long-term memory
or instantly use it by bringing it to
our attention also known as working
memory our attention can hold about
seven bits of information for a few
seconds to complete a task
if we pay Attention our brain can send
fresh memories to the long-term store
this happens especially well when we
rest during sleep we tend to consolidate
important things and discard others
which we then forget
the long-term memory is a vast library
of stories experiences facts and
Concepts some of which we can recall for
life and others we are unable to
remember the next day inside this
long-term store are again different
types of memories
there are episodic memories which are
chunks of detailed information with a
high emotional value such as all your
stories some of which you might be able
to recall in great detail like the first
day of school or your first kiss maybe
you can even recall some specific
thoughts from that day
there are semantic memories things like
facts or general knowledge repeated
episodic memories like the way to school
can also over time turn into semantic
information you can think of such
memories as a large network of ideas if
you see a particular shape you may think
gorilla ape human intelligence
episodic and semantic memories are known
as explicit memories they are conscious
Recollections they are all the
information and experiences we know we
hold
[Music]
there are also implicit memories skills
and things you are not aware of the
process of walking relies on muscle
memory you've learned it by trying and
failing and today you have no idea how
you actually do it implicit memories are
also at work when we unconsciously react
to a stimulus a process known as
conditioning
to make things more complicated our
memories often change sometimes we
forget Parts sometimes we add new
details to old memories in response to
how we feel right now when we think of a
holiday we took with someone we don't
like anymore a trip that was actually
nice might be remembered as unpleasant
today
so next time you see this or that shape
you might want to pause and pay tribute
to the fact that there are more
Connections in your brain than stars in
the universe here to help you organize
inputs thoughts and memories to get you
through life
[Music]
now the best thing about memories is
still creating them trying new things
failing and then trying them again is
one good way to do just that
foreign
[Music]
if you like how we explain complicated
ideas in simple cartoon animation you
can support us visit patreon.com Sprouts
just visit us learn how it works and
what's in it for you we hope to see you
there
and if you are a parent or educator
check out our website
sproutschools.com there you can find
this and other video lessons additional
resources and classroom activities